ronaldo lopez on for his ninth start
he's also worked out of the bullpen he's
three and three his era is very good
it's in the low threes
one and two
swing and a miss off the slider two gone
zeros on the board white sox will face
the latest addition
to this reds team the major league debut
for the tall right-hander riley o'brien
one up one down it'll bring up luis
roberts
that falls drilled to center field
and gone it does carry out of here
luis robert shocks another baseball and
it's one nothing
that's ball four grand dolls on again
and eloy's coming up here in the first
here's the 2-2 pitch and he didn't want
to do it but he chased a breaking ball
in the dirt outside and he is down on
strikes eloy ximena has retired and that
is the first major league strikeout for
riley o'brien
bottle right through the shift skips
under cesar hernandez's glove he's on
base in 12 straight games
as a team they've been hit a ton he pops
it up
shallow right hernandez has a beat on it
and he'll make the catch right near the
foul line but in fair territory johan
mankata hitting sixth tonight will lead
it off here in the second three and two
for monkatta
johan crushes this ball into right field
there's a 100
chance it's leaving and it's two nothing
before that pitch he had about a three
percent chance of hitting it out and for
the thirteenth time this year he has hit
it out
ball four leory garcia takes another
walk
[Applause]
struck him out great change up right
there
three and two and this is downstairs
it's 12-4 cesar
took ball three took fall four two on
one out for tim anderson
reds down to deuce two on one out top of
the order due up luis sessa is in from
the bullpen
and he goes down swinging
sesame to the fray strikes out tim
anderson two down
great pitch from cesa set up ground doll
three pitch k
on the ground first base side that's a
base knock for eloy jimenez
one ball two strikes swinging that's on
the ground there comes india moving to
his left fields throws out
once again schrock in awe of lopez's
stuff one gone
a couple of fastballs now three and two
is a slider and castigatos goes down
as garcia rips this ball right of center
and that's down around friedel all the
way to the track leori's gonna go
let's see how far it is to third super
joe's got the windmill out there goes
the helmet from the plate is intact
well with what he's accomplished this
year these fans absolutely love him and
why not
man has a smile on his face all the time
and here's gavin sheets
gavin sheets gives it a ride into right
field that's a home run and it's three
to nothing
the conventional way
that's home run number 10 for gavin
given his 27th run
radio suarez flied out first pitch his
first time he is on a season-long
seven-game hit streak
oh hey eugenio suarez center field
robert back suckala
30 home runs for a eugenio suarez reds
on the board it's three to one
i bet he's smiling now
line to center and down in front of
friedel who had to break it down and now
it gets past him and eloy's on his way
to second base
tough night in center field for
cincinnati
deloitte's second
and the 3-0 is
called ball four
there's a bunt third base side suarez on
the charge near home run
and a bun jimenez to third moncada to
second here comes gavin sheets
through the left side that's a base hit
eloise easily home you one's got a stop
sign
and the socks
hey look it's a non-home run rbi and
it's four to one so they're at the
corners a run in trying to build on it
stevenson draws himself away from the
conversation long enough to get a demo
he did not get him at first base i don't
believe
we will see
he's safe at first yeah you're right on
that yeah
well done by instant replay as here
comes the call and it is
safe
sox take a 5-1 lead
jose ruiz comes on and ronaldo lopez was
just brilliant tonight
castillano's clubs won over short his
first reach today
in a game situation
stevenson to right
castillano sprints up to second
to short tim gets around it got it to
second hernandez that's a double play
kids the o2 pitch and farmer bales out
of the way of a ball inside at his feet
it actually hit him
to third kicks off the glove of mulcata
both mid safe farmer to second
second base
cesar and tim flashing across double
play
time after time after time aaron bummer
gives you ground balls and there's the
two
this down the left field line from cesar
hernandez is a fair ball take a drink
extra bases on the way
it's a one-out double
suarez back now everybody else as well
against robert with two outs
oh my goodness gracious
get out the telescope
luis robert makes it 7-1
he got literally every bit of that one a
first ball fastball unloaded on it
second home run of the night
the new pitcher of the ball game it is
matt foster
on to the 35th time is era up over six
oh one
to second base hernandez
the sox win
number 90 of the year in the win column
and home runs galore tonight